within six months that group increased
sales by 100
million dollars jesus 100 million
dollars i said holy sh
right this is working in five seconds
flat
worry can hijack your mind fear can take
over and the smallest moves that you
really want to make can seem
terrifying the opposite is also true
why don't they teach us how to work
through wounds you don't get invited to
a birthday party in fifth grade there is
a wound there you lose a love when
you're
16. there is a wound there you start a
business when you're
22. there is trauma there
want to be happy live a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five ways to
get in control of your life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one train your subconscious mind with
john assaraf
this is going back sometimes i think in
1992 we were stuck
but i knew there was more possibility
there was there was room for growth
and i wanted to figure out if the stuff
that i did in the 80s when i was a kid
you know that broke free would it work
with some of my agents and so
we took 75 agents randomly agents said
hey do you want to get into a six-month
program to like
retrain your brain your subconscious
brain around your beliefs about what is
possible for you to achieve
around your habits of what you have to
do in order to achieve that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind
and so for six months they had to go
through a process of listening to
certain audio tapes
reading reading certain materials every
day and following the process of
training their brain specifically their
subconscious brain
which controls 95 to 98 of all of our
thoughts emotions and behaviors today
and within six months that group
increased sales by 100
million dollars jesus 100 million
dollars i said holy sh
right this is working and so we started
to teach
some of what we teach now in neurogym
actually now we have the technologies we
have the systems that are far better
than what we did back in the 90s
and we went from 1.2 billion to 4.5
billion a year and it wasn't because we
taught them any more
skills to be real estate agents we
taught them how to change the way they
thought about themselves we taught them
how to
change their habits our agents who made
750 000
or more were in front of a client 75 of
the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like
why are you doing that like why aren't
you in front of people
that are gonna help you earn more income
oh well we're busy doing this and doing
this and doing this
and they had stories and excuses and
reasons why
and so part of the work that i love to
do now
is is really help people understand what
is your story
like what's the story you're telling so
because we all have a story we have a
money story a relationship story a
health story
we have a story for everything and then
that story keeps recreating
our lives over and over and over again
and we have beliefs that support the
story we have habits that support the
story we have people that support the
story we have systems that support our
story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
way number two
focus on what you can control with oprah
winfrey
focusing on what you can control and
what you can't because
worry as you know doesn't change
anything i think about
all of us who had plans for the two
months that we've been in lockdown
who had things that we were worried
about that never even happened
so more than anything this time shows us
that we don't have any control over that
so focusing on what you do have control
over instead of what you don't have
control over and releasing it releasing
it you know a part of my morning
meditation i have these like cards i
pull
um and this morning i ran across this
by someone named achan cha i don't know
who that is but
it says do everything with a mind that
lets go
if you let go a little you will have a
little peace
if you let go a lot you will have a lot
of peace if you let go completely
you will know complete peace and freedom
your struggles with the world
will come to an end in direct proportion
to how you're able to let go
i know those are words that may not
resonate
in this moment but it is true the more
you can just focus on
what can i handle i can't handle that
i'm going to do that
way number three ignore other people's
opinions with tom bilyeu how do you
control your mind and not allow people's
opinions of you
to dictate your life all right this one
is really easy to explain and i get how
difficult it is to actually do
as humans we want to connect with other
people we
want to be appreciated and liked that
that is universal
but at the end of the day you can't care
more about what people think of you than
you think of yourself
and that needs to become the mantra that
you build into your life
in fact the theme of today's episode i'm
going to say is taking control of your
life
and these first two statements are all
about that are these first two questions
you can't control your own life you
can't control your own mind
if you allow yourself to care more about
what other people think of you than you
think of yourself
so that needs to be the compass by which
you steer now that doesn't mean that it
isn't going to suck
when people disapprove of you they say
they don't like what you're doing
man that's hard i'm telling you right
now that is still hard for me and this
is something that i put a lot of energy
into
but at the end of the day even when it
stings even when it hurts i know
i need to be true to myself i need to be
true to my vision i need to be true
to what gives me energy what i'm trying
to accomplish my goals the things that
i've really thought about that i'm
sitting with
they're a part of me they're a part of
my identity they are what i want to
do and become
now if somebody's trying to knock me off
that path by criticizing me
even if it hurts i know what i'm trying
to accomplish in my life
i know what i want to feel about myself
in my life and i let that be
the barometer by which i judge the state
of things i let that be
my true north by which i steer
the more i think about it the more i'm
coming to the realization
that what you think about yourself
is the ultimate goal
it's the ultimate thing it's the
ultimate reward or punishment
but what you think about yourself
is at the end of the day the single most
important thing and so
beginning to have a relationship with
yourself of sitting quietly and this may
be
one of the reasons that meditating is so
important that you can
actually sit quietly think about
who you are now what you think about
yourself who you want to become
what price you're willing to pay to get
there and then actually going down that
path to become that person
that at the end of the day is the thing
that is going to bring you happiness and
fulfillment
but you really have to think about who
you want to become
and to not be trapped by your past but
do that put
time and energy into thinking about what
do i want to think about myself
and quite honestly what do i think about
myself right now
if you steer by that it becomes very
easy to ignore other people
what's up everybody i want to talk about
the amazing book by evan carmichael
built
to serve i want to read you guys a
section this is from
a part under the heading of your pain is
your strength this is the fundamental
mind shift that most people
never make but is required for success
the pain that you went through
that you're trying to forget it's your
strength
it's the way through it's your answer
that pain is how you become the tree
you've experienced the pain grow from it
and are stronger now and are able to
help others who need
the support so there it is your pain
is the very thing that's going to get
you through it's kind of like what ryan
holliday says the obstacle
is the way all right guys check it out
build to serve by evan carmichael who
can teach a master class on how to be a
badass and be good to people
dude's rad check out his book a lot of
amazing stuff in there
way number four use the five second rule
with mel robbins
most of us don't even realize how often
we hesitate start doubting ourselves and
get stuck
analyzing things to death i keep talking
about how you can change your life in
five seconds and that's because
in five seconds flat worry can hijack
your mind
fear can take over and the smallest
moves that you really want to make can
seem
terrifying the opposite is also true
in five seconds flat you can take
control back
do you know how often you hesitate
and stop yourself all day
long there's actually a neurological
reason why
change is so hard your brain is designed
to stop you from changing let me explain
you see change requires you to do things
that are uncertain
scary or new your brain is
designed to protect you from doing
things
that are uncertain scary or new what's
your brain's
favorite way to protect you to trap you
in your head
by making you overthink i've studied and
interviewed the leading researchers in
psychology and human behavior and what
they've taught me
is that the moment the moment you want
to change
break a habit or do something hard or
scary and you hesitate
your brain goes to work to stop you now
there's all kinds of fancy names for
this
cognitive biases the paradox of choice
the psychological immune system the
spotlight effect i could name
hundreds of them you don't need to know
the fancy names
you just need to know one simple fact
there is a system
in your head that is stopping you every
step of the way
and the five-second rule is the only
tool that you need
to beat it so how does the five-second
rule beat the system in your head
there are two explanations first i'm
going to give you the simple one
then i'm going to explain the science at
its most
basic level the five-second rule is a
tool
that helps you take action it gets you
out of your head
and that's the secret you've got to stop
thinking
and start living before the system in
your head has a chance
to stop you now let's talk about the
science
the five-second rule leverages proven
principles in modern psychology and
there are literally hundreds of examples
that i could point to
but in this video we're just going to
focus on five of them
first let's talk about two concepts one
called locus of control
the second called a bias toward action
so a locus of control is a foundational
principle in psychology you should
google it
back in the day researchers figured out
that there are basically two kinds of
people
people that believe that they're in
control of their lives
and folks that believe that life is just
happening to them and they're a victim
of whatever might happen now when you
look at these two types of people
people that have an internal locus of
control a belief that they're in control
of their lives
they're happier they're more successful
more productive
so the question becomes how do you
create
an internal locus of control in yourself
the answer is simple it's called a bias
toward
action so a bias toward action is a
psychological principle that means
you're the kind of person that has a
bias toward taking action
instead of a bias toward thinking
how do you create a bias toward action
you guessed it
the five second rule the five second
rule is a tool that will teach you
how to take action and over time as you
use it
you not only learn how to take action
you become the kind of person that
operates with a bias
toward taking action and when you take
action
over and over and over on your instincts
on your desires on your commitments
guess what you get
you build an internal locus of control
you become the kind of person
that believes that you're in control of
your life because you're proving it to
yourself
five second decision at a time and way
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is release your toxic beliefs with robin
sharma
a lot of people listening may be
thinking jay i've been trying to work on
my health for a while
i've been trying to work on my mindset
you know i know i've got emotional stuff
to deal with and yeah i'm kind of
getting to that soul set right like like
you said like i'm not i'm not even sure
i'm there yet
habit formation you talk about the habit
formation protocol right you talk about
actually building habits and i
personally feel that
building and breaking habits should have
been the first thing we learned at
school
because it feel it feels like the thing
that affects our whole lives i look at
any change and it's always about habits
walk us through your
approach to building and breaking habits
absolutely and i totally agree with you
jay
they teach us history and they teach us
arithmetic they teach us geography and
they teach us
you know whatever other language is in
school
why don't they teach us before interior
empires why don't they teach
us you said something very powerful
why don't they teach us how to work
through wounds you don't get invited to
a birthday party in fifth grade there
was a wound there you lose a love when
you're 16.
there is a wound there you start a
business when you're 22
there is trauma there and i think that
is in many ways the missing
link in leadership and personal mastery
and that's
really you know i'm passionate about the
5am club
because i get into that in in the book
and i worked four years on the book but
it's really 22 years of my
my learnings and teaching in the book
and that is a missing link because
everyone's talking about psychology and
people are talking about habits and i'll
answer your question of course
but what about dealing with trauma you
know carl jung said we all have this
shadow side i mean
we all have this well of repressed pain
and anyone who's listening who goes well
that's not me
it's subconscious so a lot unless you've
done the work you don't even know about
it
but it's that pain and self-loathing and
self-hatred
in the 5-m club i say you know we have a
magic inside of us the saints call it
the light or
god or nature or luminosity
and what happens is when you do the work
to release your toxic beliefs
and move through your pain and how do
you do it you just feel it
and as you feel through all the toxicity
and the hurt and the wounding and the
disappointment that's called a human
journey
what is left as you release it you
access your light
you access your primal genius you access
creativity you're productive because you
don't have all this emotional
baggage you're carrying through the day
you've you know
i believe that the real artist the real
key to success is joy and inner peace
like that's why
a lot of the billionaires they have all
the things and they're not happy
you our nature is joy
peace bliss love
and when you release that trauma
it just shows up because that's who we
truly are
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
you have to be your biggest critic as
well as your biggest cheerleader
most of us will be our own worst critics
but not our own biggest cheerleaders
some of us
will be our own biggest cheerleaders but
not self-criticize enough
you need to be both critic and
cheerleader
and have the self-awareness to know
which one you need right now most
in the moment so monday is my mentoring
day and this past monday i was mentoring
alex who's on my team he helps me run
toronto dance salsa
and i recently gave him an exercise that
i call the pillow test where
every night before you go to bed you're
scoring yourself out of 10
for how you felt the effort was for the
day not the results that you got but
the effort and he created his score [ __ ]
out of 10 what leads to a 10 for him
and one of the things he was doing was
if you got a 9 out of 10
feeling like oh i got 90 it's a pretty
good day and i was telling him no that's
not enough
that 9 out of 10 does not equate to 90
on a test you should be hitting 10 out
of 10
every time unless you're proud of the
reason
why you didn't hit it when when i broke
my neck and it was on my tour
and i still when i did instagram live
sessions
i committed i was gonna do an instagram
live every day and i was doing half an
hour to an hour every day
my first instagram live in the hospital
was for like four minutes five minutes
and i you know i started getting
lazy-eyed and post
it wasn't the best result but i still
did it i still showed up
i'm still proud of my effort and so he
said well how do i know the difference
how do i know if that 9-10 is something
that is amazing
or or something really bad at the end of
the day you have to look at that list
you have to look at what you did for the
day and ask yourself
are you proud of the effort that you put
in i think we're way too easy on
ourselves i think too often we're just
too easy on ourselves we're not
a harsh enough critic on ourselves that
you know you're capable of doing more
and so for me i'll default to 95 of the
time
i'm my critic it's based off of a pillar
of love right at the foundation of
self-love
when you love yourself you can be way
harder on yourself way harder on
yourself than other people are
i think we should be hard on ourselves
95 of the time
and then five percent of the time you
have to be actually more gentle on
yourself
five percent of the time you got to
figure out you know what
i did a good job i'm proud of what i did
today
when you're feeling really low and in
the hole and and borderline depressed
getting harder on yourself isn't gonna
work right it just
further creates depression so that's
when you need to be gentle in yourself
you need to pat yourself on the back
more and say you're doing the best that
you can
sometimes that means just getting out of
bed is doing the best that you can
again when i broke my neck just getting
out of bed was the best that i could
on some days but more often than not you
can go harder
you could do more you need to be your
own biggest critic more
so that's the balance is being both your
biggest cheerleader
and your biggest critic and having a
self-awareness to know
which one you need more right now in the
moment to help you move forward
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want to know how to hack your brain
and condition your mind for success
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there